hey seven today I'm answering a question
from one of my YouTube viewers Michelle
who wrote in asking about Evernote and
how to organize your notebooks and
receipts and this was something that can
cause a lot of frustration a lot of
suffering for entrepreneurs use you want
the you want to free up your time and
free up the paper and free up all the
clutter around your desk and a great way
to do it is to scan everything you have
into Evernote but you have to make sure
that then it's easy to find and you can
quickly get access to all of the
receipts and in a timely manner and
create your reports and do all that
stuff it's supposed to save your time
not cost you more time so the question
of the campaign from Michelle was how
would you suggest organizing my three
areas of receipts so secondly do as
follows personal receipts 2013 personal
rentals 2013 personal or whatever sand
receipts 2013 and then target I need to
simplify my notebooks and tags any
thoughts or ideas so the one thing that
would think about here this is a great
way to do it but what I found really
helpful is to use your stocks a little
bit more thoroughly
so the challenge you're going to have
here is what happens when you have the
next year and the next year in the next
year this might work for one year but
you want to think long-term and how are
you going to use this for every year
that you need to create your receipts
and keep track of things for so show you
what I do I just want this very similar
I just use stacks so the more you use
Evernote to keep track of different
things in your life the better you need
to organize your notebooks and your
stacks you can find it now you can
always do a full-text search if you know
exactly what you're looking for but if
you're browsing you need to have a
logical and clear way to be able to find
all the information you're looking for
so you can see I use Evernote for a lot
of stuff for my book business notes
personal notes an investment I've made
in the company my business receipts
family receipts lots of different stuff
that I've used it for that particular
question from Michelle was talking about
receipts so I'll show you how I do it
both on a personal level and a business
level so I keep track of business
receipts here and you can see how I've
done it
what I typically do is I have my stock
that's called business receipts and then
I have notebooks for half the year so my
year-end is actually in the middle of
the year it's the end of the second
quarter so I'll keep track of my
receipts from first and second quarter
and then later in the year third and
fourth quarter first and second quarter
third and fourth quarter instead of just
doing the whole year I break it down by
quarter because my urines in the middle
so it's easy for me to find the
information and the cutoff point that my
accountant needs for all his stuff so
that's how I do it and then within here
if I click I can see all of the
individual receipts that I have
collected I do something similar on
family receipts you can see here I just
do this by the year since I'm just
keeping track for personal reasons not
for any business reasons I don't have a
personal year-end that I need to worry
about so I just keep track and scan them
all in here so your approach is great
it's it's good to clearly label what
each one is going to be your challenge
is going to be as you get into more year
so think beyond 2013 and go 14 15 16 and
so on you want to be able to quickly
find those receipts in an illogical way
if you are just filled with tons of
notebooks and no logical way to organize
them then you could be quickly drowning
in trying to find out the right
information so again the simple answer
here is to create a stack so all of
these similar notebooks are all about
business receipts so the in your
question here you're talking about
personal receipts Rental receipts and
whatever thus and receipts are so those
would all be notebooks but within a
stock so I'd have a stack called
personal receipts and in 2013 14 15 16
do it again for personal receipts do it
again for your rentals do it again for
sand so each one has its own stack and
then the notebooks are specific to the
year so that's how I've done it I found
that super helpful if I need to browse
it's easy to go through and find it and
if I need to do a search because I'm
looking for something in particular I
can always do my search either on the
specific notebook on the stack or
everything that I have included
hopefully that helps if you guys like
this video give it a thumbs up below let
me know you liked it I love to hear what
you have to think you have a question
about Evernote you have a different way
to solve it leave it in the comments
below if you have a different question
about your business I'd love to hear
from you and I'll make a video response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon